jude is waiting at the airport to hop on
her flight back home
when she realizes that she missed making
an important bank payment
she connects her laptop to the public
wi-fi at the airport and goes ahead to
carry out the bank transaction
everything goes well and jude completes
her transaction
after a couple of days she was wiped off
her feet
when she learned that her bank account
was subjected to a cyber attack
and a hefty amount was wiped from her
account
after getting in touch with the bank
authority she learned that her account
was hacked at the airport
she then realized that the public wifi
she used might have caused her this
trouble
jude wishes that had her bank transfer
escaped the hacker's eyes
she would not have been a victim of a
cyber attack
bank officials advise her to use a vpn
for future transactions
especially when connecting to an open or
public network
like most of us jude had come across the
term vpn
several times but didn't know much about
it and
little did she think that the
repercussions of not using a vpn
would be this bad let's understand how
the hacker would have exploited jude's
transaction
in the absence of a vpn in this process
jude's computer first connects to the
internet service provider
isp which provides access to the
internet
she sends her details to the bank's
server using her ip address
internet protocol address or ip address
is a unique address that recognizes a
particular device
be it a laptop or a smartphone on the
internet when these details pass through
the public network
the hacker who passively watches the
network traffic
intercepts it this is a passive cyber
attack
where the hacker collects jude's bank
details without being detected
more often or not in such an attack
payment information is likely to be
stolen
the targeted data here are the victim's
username passwords and other personal
information
such an unsecured connection exposed
jude's ip address
and bank details to the hacker when it
passed through the public network
so would you have been able to secure
her transaction with the help of a vpn
well yes picture jude's bank transaction
to be happening in a tunnel that is
invisible to the hacker
in such a case the hacker will not be
able to spot a transaction
and that is precisely what a vpn does
a virtual private network more often
known as vpn
creates a secure tunnel between your
device and the internet
for using a vpn jude's first step would
be to install software-based technology
known as the vpn client on her laptop or
smartphone
that would let her establish a secure
connection the vpn client connects to
the wi-fi
and then to the isp here the vpn client
encrypts jude's information using vpn
protocols
data is encrypted to make sure it is
secure next
the vpn client establishes a vpn tunnel
within the public network
that connects to the vpn server the vpn
tunnel protects jude's information from
being intercepted by the hacker
jude's ip address and actual location
are changed at the vpn server
to enable a private and secure
connection finally
the vpn server connects to jude's bank
server in the last step
where the encrypted message is decrypted
this way
jude's original ip address is hidden by
the vpn
and the vpn tunnel protects her data
from being hacked
this explains how vpn makes your data
anonymous
and secure when it passes through the
public network
and the difference between a normal
connection and a vpn connection
after learning about this jude was
certain that she should start using a
vpn to carry out her online transactions
in the future
this is also applicable to each one of
us even if you work remotely or connect
to public wi-fi
using a vpn is the safest option
in addition to providing a secure
encrypted data transfer
vpns are also used to disguise your
whereabouts
and give you access to regional web
content vpn servers
act as proxies on the internet this way
your actual location cannot be
established
vbn enables you to spoof your location
and switch to a server to another
country
and thereby change your location for
example
by doing so you can watch any content on
netflix that might be unavailable for
your region
so here's a question for you from the
given options below
identify the correct flow of a vpn
connection
a
b
c
d
do give it a thought and leave your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
given the current scenario cyber attacks
are on the rise
now more than ever so we have to stay
alert and protect our digital
information
if you are interested in protecting
networks and computers from cyber
criminals
a cyber security career is what you
should venture into
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn
and become a cyber security expert we
hope you enjoyed this video
if you did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
channel and click on the bell icon for
more on the latest technologies and
trends
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
you